in today's world we've got a lot of guys
that are feeling alone and lonely what
do I do it's suppressing find people I
don't know how to meet
people I don't want to talk girls or
women or this toxic Narrative of
feminism is too difficult to deal with I
don't get any results in dating apps I
don't want to use dating apps cold
approach is too much I don't know where
to meet people I don't know where where
to meet women I don't know where to meet
you know good guys good men that are
good being men sort of thing and it's
like this this real world story of what
happened when I was 16 in this junior
Ranger
program shows how how quickly
friendships and bonds can form when you
spend time together doing over eight
weeks so in eight qu quick weeks we
formed a Brotherhood and a lifetime uh
friendship I know a lot of these guys um
out there still to this day um some of
the connections have been made on
Facebook although I don't really use
Facebook they actually
exist and I think one of the things you
know one of the lessons that can be
taken from the story is that you're
going to form real human connections and
not feel alone or feel loneliness when
you start doing things that you like
when you find ways to enjoy things that
you're doing as well in real life I
think that's a key thing there because
one of the big mistakes you know when I
talk to these guys they're usually
younger
men or 20s is that they're caught up in
the virtual world in the internet World
keep in mind I grew up in a time where
for the first 20 odd years of my life
there was really no internet at all
nothing it didn't even exist cell phones
were just starting to I remember I had
my first cell phone in my 20s 203 four
five something like that my mid 20s um
before that they were bricks that only
like uh you know Bay Street guys or Wall
Street guys would have these big giant
phones that probably weighed you know
five six pounds or they were Tethered to
your car with a a
cord so so I think one of the big
mistakes that guys are making today is
they're looking for connection they're
they're looking for friendships they're
looking for women you know whatever it
happens to be they're not doing it in
the real world they're not doing it in a
real life environment because a lot of
these younger guys they they grew up in
the internet era the like this
generation
today this is a big experiment this is
the first generation ever in history
that has grown up I don't have my phone
here because I charge it I keep it out
of the room when I'm doing these things
but has grown up with a screen that's
always been in front of their face
handheld device throughout their entire
life you know for the most part um they
use it when they eat they use it before
bed they use it when they get up they
use it when they're sitting on the
toilet taking a dump they use it at the
stoplight you know when they're waiting
for the light turn green they use it all
the time and they they live in this
world if it's not this world it's the
computer world or it's the console World
playing games video games you know this
sort of thing you can form guilds and
all kinds of uh Clans and tribes like I
Know video games have that integrated
into them because they because I know
that communities matter to human beings
but you're not forming an in real life
connection playing video games chatting
your little head phones on [__] talking
you know the kids or trying to
coordinate your attack and you know know
the raid or whatever is that you're
doing so don't think for a minute that
that's a substitute because I think
that's one of the big mistakes one of
the big lies one of the comforting lies
that we tell ourselves and the young men
today are telling themselves to believe
in because that doesn't equal friendship
that doesn't that's that's going to get
very
lonely now for guys that are introverted
I think this is a little bit easier I
think guys that are you know they're
extrovert it's it's you know quite a bit
harder
but you should be comfortable in your
own company right if you're not
comfortable in your own
company you're going to feel alone and
lonely you need to get comfortable with
yourself as a
companion um I can
do a couple of days
without any contact with anybody very
comfortably I can spend hours writing I
can I can spend hours watching uh videos
I can spend hours playing console games
if I wanted to project something with my
hands um because I've because I've
developed the ability to be comfortable
with myself I also know where to find
good men that are good at being men
based on the things that I've done in
the past one of the chapters in my book
I talked about why men should own
motorcycle I'll get the damn book you
guys get the damn book the second
edition is available get it okay if you
haven't read it it's it's been updated
and revised um there's there's a chapter
in that book that talks about getting a
motorcycle why I think all men should as
a right of passage own a motorcycle at
some point in their
life people get all worked up about this
not everybody but I mean I've legit had
angry emails you tell people to get
motorcycles that's irresponsible and
people are going to
die
okay but you're also going to have a lot
of fun and the chances of something bad
happening to you are relatively low if
you're a good Rider and you keep your
head on the swivel and you ride with
other guys and you do it intentionally
I'll tell you one thing anywhere you go
with a motorcycle if you're touring the
country you will always have a friend
there's always cafes there's always
Meetup spots there's always somewhere
and it doesn't matter if it's Cruisers
if it's sport bikes naked bikes asn't
matter what it is that you ride Enduros
Dr bikes you will never have a problem
meeting cool people because you already
do something cool yourself and you can
you can do that
together there was at least two or three
spots um in the greater Toronto area
that I would frequent sometimes by my
myself I would just hop on my bike andz
[__] it I'm I'm going out my girlfriend
would have pissed me off or I don't know
maybe I didn't have friends to hang out
with that night or they were busy or
working or some [__] I just get on my
bike throw some gas in the tank go down
to the cafe um we used to go down to
this one on uh Lawrence if you guys live
in Toronto you're gonna you're gonna
have to remind me of the name in the
chat but there was one down on Lawrence
east of The Da Valley Parkway um and it
was all bles there all the time and you
just go there you grab your coffee start
shooting [__] talking to guys go out for
rides and rips you would always meet
somebody new right we never sat behind a
screen or looked at a handheld device
hoping to make a connection it was it
was going out and moving and doing
something you
know humans are nomadic hun gatherers
right it's only in recent history in the
last thousand odd years that we've
evolved more into Agriculture and you
know setting up coal cities and urban
centers and you know aqueducts and water
and sewage and electricity and all this
sort of stuff that's all you know these
are all very very modern conveniences uh
sorry I I digress agriculture is 10,000
years old you know like a lot of these
Notions like marriage are a thousand or
2,000 years old you get the idea though
but a lot of these things are very very
new but when you go back to the nomatic
H gatherer days which is how we live for
a very long period of time throughout
much longer than we have lived today we
would go out together in groups probably
hiding in the bushes looking for [__] to
throw Spears at sitting there side by
side yo lothar of the Hill People yes
Rich of the unplugged Alpha tribe and
you and you'd have a conversation you
know looking for whatever it is that you
had to kill to try to bring back and
stalk it and coordinate maybe hand
signals this
is this is why today we feel
lonely the loneliness that you
feel is a prison that you build for
yourself you've
chosen that life you know um people
often complain like oh Rich you're out
of touch you've got the cars the money
successful businesses blah blah blah and
all sort of stuff you don't understand
you know how the world works it's that
the other thing
maneuver you don't like your you know
your job or whatever is you're doing
leave and go to another one you don't
like the people that you're hanging
around with move
last time I checked there's like we
don't live in Walled cities there's
nothing stopping you from going
somewhere else right yet anyway that
might be coming the government might be
bringing that down at some point in the
future but as it stands today
maneuver
right why why do we have to complicate
things unnecessarily oh I can't do this
because of that okay well you want to
sit there in misery and wallow and
self-pity and play the victim mindset or
do you want to do something to change it
right if you go to the gym ask somebody
for a
spot I've honestly probably in the last
five years now that I think about it
even before this pandemic even before
all that [__] people didn't really
ask for spots when I was a kid like when
I was in my teens in my 20s if you were
at the gym and you couldn't go you know
with your workout partner your buddy or
your roommate or whatever anybody in the
gym would do chicks included I mean you
wouldn't generally ask a chick to help
you you know spot you on the bench R Us
if you're doing three plates or some
[__] like that but anybody in the gym is
your buddy hey you know I could use a
spot over here J mind yeah no problem we
finish one over here and they come over
they spot you right that's that's a lost
art you know ask for a spot in the gym I
need a spot man I'm going for a PR big
know Big Bad Boy over here ask you know
talk to people engage them you know
they're not going
to go out of their way generally
speaking to want to get to know you if
you're the one that's feeling lonely if
you're the one that doesn't have a
network if you're the one that doesn't
have a tribe or a like-minded group of
friends you can create it but you're GNA
have to be interested in other people
you're also going to have to be
interesting you're going to have to have
some interesting hobbies and some things
going on in your life I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out